la muerte de la emblemática jueza de la
corte suprema de eeuu ruth báder
ginsburg genera polémica y
enfrentamientos en la escena política
del país mientras los demócratas bien
que su reemplazo se han nominado por el
presidente electo en las próximas
elecciones
donald trump anunció que ya evalúa
nombres
con eventos en los sitios más simbólicos
de la capital del país méxico conmemora
un nuevo aniversario de los terremotos
del 19 de septiembre de 1985 y de 2017
la fecha ya marca la historia del país y
es que el mismo día con 32 años de
diferencia la nación azteca fue
atravesada por la tragedia
y mientras tanto de tailandia miles de
personas salieron a las calles de
bangkok para pedir reformas democráticas
en movimiento protagonizado
principalmente por estudiantes y
opositores y de reformar la constitución
del país también elecciones libres y
limitar el poder de la monarquía
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 saludamos a toda
la audiencia de france 24 en español
gracias por acompañarnos como ya es
habitual y santiago garcía y comenzamos
esta emisión en eeuu donde la muerte de
la emblemática jueza de la corte suprema
hablamos por supuesto del ruth báder
ginsburg ya genera polémicas en medio de
la campaña presidencial mientras miles
de personas continúan homenajeando a
este icono de los derechos de la mujer
el vacío que deja aquí es word pone al
control de la corte suprema
estadounidense en el centro de la
carrera hacia la casa blanca y en el
foco de la polémica está quién es el que
debería denominar su reemplazo por su
parte donald trump anunció que ya está
evaluando en hombres y que probablemente
se trate de una mujer
voy a ver james jones tenemos una
obligación nosotros ganamos y tenemos
una obligación como ganadores de elegir
a quien queramos no debe ser el
siguiente presidente espero ser el
próximo presidente pero ahora estamos
aquí y tenemos una obligación con los
millones de personas que nos pusieron
aquí
pero si seguimos en eeuu nuevo episodio
en la batalla entre washington y la red
social china tick tock ahora el
presidente de donald trump parece haber
dado un giro en su postura al anunciar
que va a aprobar un acuerdo entre la
compañía estadounidense oracle y tick
tock para que ésta continúe operando en
el país he dado mi bendición al trato
aprobé el concepto del acuerdo dijo el
mandatario en un anuncio que generó
sorpresa dado que horas antes el
departamento de comercio estadounidense
había informado que a partir del 20 de
septiembre quedaban prohibidas todas las
descargas y actualizaciones de 'tik tok'
continuamos con noticias de américa
latina y vamos a mexico que recordó a
las víctimas de los terremotos del 19 de
septiembre de 1985 y de 2017 con eventos
en los sitios más afectados en la mayor
plaza de la capital del país por su
parte el presidente de andrés manuel
lópez obrador expresó su compromiso para
finalizar con todos los trabajos de
reconstrucción los detalles los tiene
alan austria
el 19 de septiembre es una jornada que
marca la historia de méxico
el mismo día con 32 años de diferencia
la nación azteca fue golpeada por dos
grandes terremotos en 1985 y en 2017
dolor miedo angustia y tragedia son
palabras que describen lo ocurrido en
ambas fechas cuando miles de mexicanos
vieron cómo cambiaba su vida de un
minuto para otro en 1985 méxico aprendió
que necesitaba mejores estrategias en
caso de una nueva tragedia y el temido
día llegó 32 años después la mañana del
19 de septiembre del 2017 los mexicanos
esperaban conmemorar a los fallecidos en
1985 nadie imaginaba que ese mismo día
se repitiera la catástrofe gracias a los
avances en tecnología el número de
víctimas fue mucho menor sin embargo la
ayuda para los municipios afectados no
es suficiente para la reparación de los
daños ocasionados
por los sismos
es el día en que
casualidad
lamentable
se padecieron de dos sismos
este 2020 la tragedia tiene un matiz
especial la fecha llega cuando la
pandemia del cobi 19 ha dejado más
muertos en méxico que lo ocasionado por
ambos terremotos combinados el sismo de
1985 dejó un saldo de entre 10 mil y 40
mil decesos o desaparecidos mientras que
hace tres años el terremoto dejó menos
de 400 la pandemia ya deja más de 72 mil
fallecimientos en méxico el cuarto país
con más muertes a nivel mundial y luego
de que el congreso de perú rechazara
ayer el pedido de destitución
el presidente de martinica ra acusado de
presunta participación en un caso de
corrupción hizo un llamado a la unidad
de su país sin mencionar la decisión del
congreso el mandatario pidió continuar
trabajando todos unidos por lo que
realmente importa a los peruanos y
remarcó que uno de los ejes de su
trabajo es la lucha contra la pandemia
de coronaria
en otras noticias israel vive un
particular año nuevo judío en medio de
un nuevo confinamiento por la pandemia
de coronavirus los israelíes celebran
este año nuevo con nuevas restricciones
que impiden los tradicionales planes de
reencuentros familiares y también los
festejos comunitarios las cenas
plegarias y grandes no tienen esta vez
el tono ni tampoco el ánimo tradicional
y cientos de mujeres fueron detenidas en
minsk la capital bielorrusa en una nueva
jornada de manifestaciones en la que
exigían la dimisión del presidente
alexander lukashenko alrededor de 300
mujeres fueron arrestadas en la nueva
jornada de protestas que reunió a unas
dos mil personas entre las detenidas se
encontraba la activista nina hagen scala
de 73 años que ya se ha convertido en
una figura icónica de la protesta de
bielorrusia
mientras tanto en tailandia miles de
personas salieron a las calles de
bangkok y lo hicieron para pedir la
renuncia del primer ministro así como
también reformas constitucionales y
nuevas elecciones e incluso cambiar a la
monarquía del país
en primera plana la vista de la
residencia real de tailandia miles de
manifestantes se reunieron este sábado
pidiendo reformas al gobierno y también
a la monarquía reforzar nuestras
instituciones empieza por luchar en
contra de una monarquía que ejerce mucho
poder
la monarquía per se no es un obstáculo
para la democracia
hay otros países como el reino unido-
españa dinamarca suecia o japón que
tienen monarquías pero la nuestra tiene
mucho poder
es una posición valiente a tomar en un
país donde criticar a la familia real
puede resultar en una pena de 15 años de
prisión los manifestantes piden eliminar
esas restricciones y reducir los poderes
constitucionales del rey y también
solicitan la reducción de su fortuna
estimada en 40 mil millones de dólares
un movimiento liderado por estudiantes
pidió nuevas elecciones una nueva
constitución de renuncia del primer
ministro que llegó al poder en el golpe
de estado de 2014 el último en una
docena de intentos por derrocar al
monarca militar desde que el poder
absoluto real terminó en 1932 debemos
restablecer la democracia nuestra lucha
no puede ser el mal los manifestantes
afirmaron que planean continuar con las
protestas durante la noche para llegar a
la oficina del primer ministro del
domingo un plan que el gobierno les
aconsejó no realizar desde que llegó al
poder en 2016 el rey vajiralongkorn ha
pasado la mayoría de su tiempo en
alemania
y ya son una tradición en toda europa y
por supuesto también en francia hablamos
de las jornadas del patrimonio cada año
millones de franceses visitan museos y
lugares históricos esta edición está por
supuesto marcada por un repunte de la
pandemia de coronavirus y por fuertes
restricciones pero esto no impidió la
celebración
filas de espera en las que todos los
visitantes llevan mascarillas reservas
'online' obligatorias y desinfección de
las manos antes de entrar hasta en medio
de una pandemia se celebra las jornadas
del patrimonio
es un privilegio porque hay menos
visitantes podemos conocer el lugar
tomar fotos y mucha gente y máximo 70
personas cada 30 minutos ese día en la
sombra la universidad más antigua de
francia los visitantes pueden disfrutar
del dorado del salón y julio nunca
habíamos visitado entonces llevamos los
niños a mi me parece magnífica lis y con
este año 1500 eventos fueron cancelados
sobre todo en las grandes ciudades en
cambio ningún problema para las visitas
al aire libre como en vive la visión con
el tiempo en los edificios se movieron
descubriendo la más antigua ciudad
minera de la región de patiala
tengo abuelos que fueron mineros
entonces quiero descubrir cómo vivían en
la época
aunque esté la epidemia entonces tenemos
que aprender a vivir así estando fuera
podemos tener distancia de visto en el
patrimonio local en el punto de mira
pero también lugares de historia y de
poder
bienvenidos voy a tratar de guiarles de
aquí el primer ministro hace de guía
termina en 1936 el frente popular
convirtió martín jon como la sede del
gobierno
estas jornadas del patrimonio siguen
todo el fin de semana en toda francia
finalizamos así otra emisión de noticias
sigan en france 24 y en france 24 punto
com
[Música]